One of the best known features of Jupiter
is the great red spot.
It's been there for hundreds of years, it's
a big storm, a vast hurricane on Jupiter.
And when the Voyager spacecraft got a look
at that,
it noticed you get complicated, turbulent
vortices spinning off.
What we see on Jupiter is turbulence.
Big vortices, smaller vortices, very small
vortices,
and if we could look closely - smaller and
smaller and smaller ones.
That's an example of chaos but it's chaotic
geometry.
Any geometrical object with that structure
is called a fractal.
So fractals are the geometry of chaos.
They're unlike all the usual things you get
in geometry.
You take something like a circle.
If I've got a circle and I make it bigger
and bigger and bigger,
look more closely at it, it just gets flatter
and flatter and flatter.
Nothing interesting there.
If I start with a sphere and make it bigger
and bigger,
it just seems flatter and flatter like a plane.
This is why a lot of people thought the Earth
was flat in ancient times.
Fractals are different. When you magnify them,
you see more and more and more structure.
And yet that very intricate geometry can be
created by very simple mathematical rules.
And the next demonstration is going to show
us an example
of a fractal pattern created by simple mathematical
rules.
OK, now, I need some assistance for doing
this as well.
Young man there.
OK, and your name is? - Richard.
OK, Richard, now what we've got here for you,
that's it,
you might as well stand there, is a whole
pile of stuff.
There's a triangle marked one, two, three.
Pile of red dots.
A three sided die.
It looks like an ordinary die but it's got
a 1 on that side,
and it's also got a 1 on the opposite side.
And the same for the 2 and the 3.
So, you hold that for a minute, so whatever
you throw with that
is either a 1, a 2 or a 3.
And you've also got a ruler. - OK.
So what we do is we start by putting a dot
somewhere in the triangle.
I'll put it in the middle.
Now roll that. It's a 2.
I want you to find the point half way between
that dot and corner two.
I'll pop it there if you tell me where to
put it.
That's it, let's have a measure.
OK, what's that? - 11.
OK, so about there.
And now do it again.
Three. OK, that's over there.
So half way between your new dot and 3.
About there? OK.
That's alright, we can put that one back.
And once more.
One. Half way between your new dot and one.
Right, and that would be? - 16.
OK, that's great.
OK, thank you very much.
So there's some simple mathematical rules.
Roll the die. Start from wherever you are
and go half way towards the corner that the
die has given you.
And just repeat.
The question is - what shape would you expect
to see?
Well the most likely thing you'd expect to
see is just
a sort of smeary mess in the middle of the
triangle.
But let me show you what happens if you do
it thousands and thousands of times.
Again, we'll use the computer and we'll see
exactly what pattern builds up.
OK, we start with random looking dots.
Nothing very interesting, just sitting in
the triangle.
But now we'll just speed it up a little bit.
Keep going.
And you'll start to see very, very beautiful
surprising mathematical pattern appearing
here.
This is called the Sierpinski gasket.
Gasket, all of you car mechanics will know,
a gasket is the thing you take out of your
car and it's full of holes of different sizes.
Sierpinski, Waclaw Sierpisnki was a Polish
mathematician
who invented this shape for totally different
reasons.
It's got big holes in the middle
and then in the pieces around there are smaller
holes and smaller holes
and smaller holes and smaller holes.
And mathematically those holes go on forever.
And that's typical of fractals.
Simple rules create structure on all scales,
even the finest.